each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so good afternoon everybody
welcome to my presentation today I will
talk about a first-order primal-dual
algorithm and I will show applications
of this algorithm which we find quite
promising nowadays to convex problems in
computer vision so what I present here
is joint work with alternation Boyle
mainly for the algorithmic part and the
applications part it is joint worked
with tenured Kramer's from tu min King
was pressure from IC g tu Kratz and the
students of Mauricio to abandon well peg
amico Tsonga and Godfrey cava
okay let's champion the plan for today
is first I will give a short
introduction about optimization problems
then I will consider a specific class of
programs a structured class of convex
problems and then I will present the
primal-dual algorithm to solve this
class of problems then I will comment on
recent improvement of the algorithm
which is preconditioning which makes
this pram dual algorithm applicable in a
plug-and-play fashion and then I will
show a number of different computer
vision applications let us consider the
following very general mathematical
problem optimization problem so give
them an objective function f 0 we want
to minimize this objective function with
respect to the unknown vector X and this
optimization problem is subject to a
number of constraints so if I have X
less equal than 0 its it's not
restricted to convex problems just a
general optimization problem and axis of
some vector space capital X ok this
seems to be very standard and maybe it's
naive to think that there should be some
some commercial available package to
solve this graph of class of problems
because it looks so so easy and so
structured however when you type this
problem Google you will not find a
commercial package which solves this
problem the reality is quite different
finding a solution to this very general
class of convex optimization problems
is far from being trivial so your
canister off in this book on convex
optimization says optimization problems
are unsolvable in general and everyone
should to be aware about this set
optimization is really difficult and
there's only a very small class of
problems problems which we can solve
actually let me show another slide about
the complexity bounds for global
optimization global optimization means
give my optimization problems you're
interested in the globally optimal
solution so let us restrict the
following class of problems we want to
minimize an arbitrary objective function
in a n-dimensional unit cube so that the
cube is given here so just each
dimension of this unknown vector X is
between 0 & 1 is just a unit hypercube
of course we could ask what is the lower
complexity bound to find an epsilon
accurate solution to this class complete
class of problems so we are not
interested in relatively optimistic
efficient to have an epsilon accurate
solution with respect to the objective
function an ester of showed in his book
in the same book that for L 1/2 larger
than epsilon L is the Lipschitz constant
of the objective function so a bound on
the maximum steepness of f the
complexity of any zero order method to
find an epsilon accurate solution is at
least so it's the lower bound of L over
to epsilon to the power of n n is the
number of unknowns so that means for
example if we have a very moderate
Lipschitz constant so it's not moving
too heavily this function let's say L is
2 and we require an accuracy of epsilon
is 1% and we have only 10 unknowns that
means 2 over 2 is 1 over 1% is 100
hundred to the power of 10 on the 10
unknowns is 10 to the power of 20
function cause at least to solve this
class of problems so that's really yes
boxes sorry what yeah
this is because of because you restrict
it to zero order methods that means it's
nothing less than a complete search and
in order tool to set up the grid for
this complete search you need to know
how fast is this function moving this is
exactly what the Lipschitz constant
gives you in this case here yeah it
depends on how fast is this this
function moving because if L is very
large that means it can move quite a lot
and if it's on this smoothly moving
epsilon is in F yes it's a accuracy with
respect to the objective function area
so you need somehow to combine X with
the function values and this is exactly
given by this Lipschitz constant here I
said that that means any zero order
method cannot be faster for this
complete class of problems of course not
for all those special cases then this
bound here that means 10 to the power of
20 function holds so on a standard
compute it's 30 million years only ten
unknowns and the amazing thing is that
this bound cannot be very much improved
by higher order methods that mean first
order second order methods gradient
descent Newton methods because you don't
have any any structure available for
this for this type of problems yes yes
it's used for yes
you're right and but there's no chance
to rewrite it in terms of X sometimes so
when you when you look at these
conversions rates of Nesterov and so on
this always in in the functional
objective function now that the comment
is a good comment because sometimes this
could be that though you are only an
epsilon away from the optimum energy the
solution can change quite a lot so
there's no no guarantee that this
solution or s is is somehow related to
the gap of the energy you you can trust
you if but for non smooth problems
there's no guarantee so for example you
can maybe you can set up a graph cut
problem where only for a very small
difference in energy the solution might
change quite a lot but there's no chance
to write this bount in terms of X here
but for smooth problems it's different I
will show it in the talk later on okay
let me comment a little bit about convex
vs. non convex programs so this class
now considered on the last slide is of
course a non convex class of problems so
what the difference is here
unfortunately non convex problems often
give more accurate models so when you
try to model some some problem then it's
of more easier to think in terms of non
convex moment because human tend to
thinking in hidden variable service
exactly leads to non convex problems
however in general there's no chance to
find the global minimizer and also they
research strongly depends on utilization
of course if you're very close to the
optimal solution then you will maybe
finally over minimum but it very much
depends on the initialization in this or
by state dilemma when working with non
convex Berger do have the wrong wrong
model or is it just subject to the
optimization procedure so maybe if I
could find the real problem would this
be the desired result or is the model
wrong so this Orestes dilemma
and for convex problems it's different
they are often inferior to my comics
models but very often you know what what
what are your basic approximation so for
example you know okay I did a
linearization of this thing and the
approximation here and the relaxation
there so you know that it's not maybe
the best solution but you know what's
going on so you can really analyze with
what's your minimize are giving you and
so on and of course any local minimizer
of a convex optimization problem is a
global minimizer and it's independent of
the initialization however one should
beware that convex doesn't mean easy so
you could very easily construct the
convex optimization problem which has
exponentially many unknowns so on the
system of course a very difficult
problem as well so let me consider
therefore the following structured class
of convex optimization problems we will
work on in the next slides it's given by
the objective function which consists of
two terms F and G and there is a linear
operator K involved and X is the unknown
vector so K is a linear operator from
one vector space one hilbert space X to
another Hilbert space Hilbert space
means basically a complete vector space
with an inner product and F is a mapping
of the vector space Y to are including
infinities or also functions which have
infinity as a function value are allowed
and the same is here for G and F and G
are convex lower semi continuous
functions and the main assumption we do
here is that F and G are simple that
means we have an idea of the structure
of F and G so we for example it could be
a sum over small functions so we assume
that they are simple functional with
known structure in simple more precisely
means that they have been easy to
compute proximity operator the proximity
operator is an auxiliary optimization
problem where don't want to minimize the
complete energy F plus G
just want to minimize one of these two
terms for example chi blast something
quadratic or only F plus something
quadratic and the solution to this
auxiliary optimization problem is called
the proximity operator proximity
therefore because set is fixed and you
are only allowed to move in the
proximity of set with X but you at the
same times aim at minimizing one of
these two terms at the efforts called
proximity operator and in operator
notation it is written in this fancy way
here so this is just this is equivalent
to the argument that minimizes this
optimization problem here so it turns
out that many standard problems can be
cast in this framework here so one of
the most simple stoy problem is rof
image denoising it has been introduced
by juden ausrotten me in 1992 for H
preserving image denoising and I'm sure
many of you know this model here and the
model consists of exactly two terms one
here is the l1 norm of the image
gradient so 2 1 means it's the 2 norm
with respect to the length of the
gradient and the 1 norm with respect to
the domain of the image and it has a
quadratic data terms F is they give me
possibly noisy data so that means you
want to find a very close approximation
to F but which should have low variation
measured in terms of this l1 norm of the
gradient here so now we can try to cast
this into the class of problems I've
mentioned the previous slide it's easy
to see that X is just R to the power of
n assuming n pixels wise x times x axis
you hear the linear operators the novel
operator is just a huge matrix a sparse
matrix where there's some finite
differences approximation of the
gradient inside F is exactly this 2 1
norm and she is the quadratic l2 norm
here so therefore the proximity
operators are very easy to compute for F
it's a point by sum of a quadratic
function plus
this tune um here and this is well-known
that this can be solved by pointless
trinket operations soft shrinkage and
forty the proximity operators the sum of
something patriotic pointless blast
something quadratic pointless that's
very very easy so you can really solve
this very efficiently point wise that
means pointers for each pixel in your
image so another different important
class of problems is the so called basis
pursuit problem in compressed sensing
which also fits into this class of
problems the idea here is that you have
given some noise the measurement vector
P and you have given a basis for example
a very flat basis and you want to find
an approximation of P in this basis and
exist a coefficient vector with respect
to this basis and here the l1 norm is
used to have a sparse representation so
that's the basic idea of this
reconstruction algorithms in compress
sensing another class of problems which
is exactly can exactly be cast in this
class of problems is a linear support
vector machine so I think you are all
familiar with linear support vector
machines are you looking for a
hyperplane that were you and and your
bias such that this hinge loss here
which is a non smooth function is
minimized and of course this is a
realization term for W so that the
vector W should be as small as possible
this can exactly be written or cast in
this case of progress and last but not
least channel linear program mean
problems exactly fit into this class of
problems so here you have this linear
objective function and this is subject
to equality constraints and
dispositively constraints or you
considered inequality formats is
everything the same because it can be
converted from one form into the other
okay so the most important concept in
convex optimization is duality and
duality comes through different concepts
you can derive it through different
concepts one is the so called convex
conjugate function so give me a function
f of X you can compute the convex
conjugate f star of y
which is given by this transformation at
that step lashon's offensive
transformational Rockefeller transform
also called complex conjugate and the
important thing here is if f of X is a
convex lower semi continuous function
and you apply this transformation twice
you again get back your original
function f of X and if f of X is not
convex then you and you apply this
transformation twice you get back there
the largest convex hull over your non
convex function so our initial problem
which I call now the primer here was
exactly this objective function if F K X
plus G of X and I apply this formula to
the first term here then I arrive at the
so-called primal dual formulation you
now see I did not touch G of X it's the
same I just apply this transformation to
F here which gives me this term minus
this term here so this is called not a
primer dual but because Y is the dual
variable and you have both the primal in
the tool in your objective function this
is now no longer a minimization problem
it's not a 7-point problem because you
minimize in X and maximize in Y and
doing the same for T I arrive at the so
called dual problem now so f star and T
star are now they the conjugate
functions of F and G and VY is the dual
and K star is the adjoint operator of K
so in our terminology it's just a matrix
transpose here because we have two real
numbers here so the good thing about
this transformation is that we can now
compute the so-called duality gap which
is exactly the difference of the primal
objective - the dual objective here and
it is known that if the primal dual get
vanishes we have found an optimal primal
dual pair pair x and y of course given
that F and G are convex functions
otherwise only weak duality will hold
so in our work we focus on the primary
dual formulation so we don't use the
primary neither the dual we just take
this in-between think because it gives
us access to the primal in the tool and
sometimes it makes it easier to find
relaxations of non convex problems so
here's again the primary dual
formulation or the subtle point
formulation and a saddle point has to
fulfill the following oil Oerlikons
equations which is simply the functional
derivative furious with respect to y
here gives KX plus minus sub gradient F
F star of y and 0 should be contained in
this set here and the same for the
primer and if zero is contained in this
set on the left hand side they may have
found the saddle point so this is a
little bit fancy so normally when when
minimizing a function you say okay is
equal zero but you should be aware that
we don't deal with differentiable
functions we can also have non
differentiable function then we need the
notion of sub gradient which is not a
single value which is a set of different
gradients so basic is a set of
hyperplanes therefore on the left hand
side here is a set because this is a set
here and as long as 0 is contained here
then we found a set point so this is the
example for a saddle point
so you minimizing here the primer and
maximizing the tour here in tears the
setting point to decide so it's a
stationary point here yeah it's just
equal zero here you have the gradient
and here equal zero yes exactly yes ok
so for this class of problems a number
of different methods exist which can be
used to solve these class of problems
one of these a list algorithm is sister
could error who have it's algorithm for
finding set points States back to 58 and
if you don't know error and hoods are
both Nobel Prize winners the funny thing
is who it's I think got his Nobel Prize
in Economics
when he was 90 years old so it was 2007
so it's amazing
one of the most general algorithms is
the so called proximal point algorithm
which has been studied or introduced by
martini and then more deeply developed
by Rockefeller and mercy Lyon and this
is a very general algorithm which can be
applied to very general class of convex
problems but the problem is that it's
rather conceptual so it's not
implementable the algorithm because each
step of the approximate point algorithm
is as difficult as the problem itself
but there exists some splitting
techniques based on the approximate
point algorithm for example the ad mm
alternating Direction method of
multipliers which is equivalent to the
augmented Lagrangian approach or
recently called this brick flip split
correct man I'll give me you heard about
it they are all equivalent to split
things based on this proximal point
algorithm and there is this class of so
good extra gradient methods introduced
back copy leverage and pop off and then
more cheaply start when they named
Akatsuki quite recently and of course
there is very well-known ester ops
method which has now been applied to
different problems in science machine
learning computer vision and even other
types of programs which can also be
applied to this class of problems but
the idea here is that it doesn't work on
there a non differentiable function you
have to apply some smoothing step before
and then to solve this smooth
approximation
so in our work we propose the following
first-order primal-dual algorithm so
it's very easy to only has two steps so
first we have to choose two time steps
the primer time step tau and the dual
Sigma larger than zero of course then we
have to choose some parameter theta let
us fix it to one here and some in
attorney's ation which is arbitrary it
even doesn't have to be feasible here
and then the recent iterations are the
following we update X and and Y and as
follows so yn plus 1 is given by some
gradient s sent here using the linear
operator and then applying the proximity
operator with respect to F star and then
due to the same creating decent now
because in the primary we minimize with
respect to the giant operator and using
this point from the previous three
previous iteration and then apply the
proximity operator again so it's just
basically alternating gradient ascent in
the dual in gradient descent in the
primer so one thing very important here
is that we don't take just a point xn
from the previous iteration we take a
linear combination of N and n minus 1
here and this is very important to
ensure convergence of the algorithm can
be seen as an over relaxation so
normally if you alternatingly minimize
in the primary and maximize in dual one
will always be behind the other so maybe
the problem is is one step before the
tool and using this extrapolation here
you ensure that both run at the same
time so that there's a concurrent
minimization maximization in the primary
toward yes
you mean tau and Sigma theater is fixed
it has to be equal to one to prove
convergence so when you when you try to
prove convergence of this area you see
that theta has to be equal to one
because for four other classes of the
province this is for the complete class
where you have something smooth then we
found the acceleration where the theta
actually varies so bad for for the plane
algorithm which can be applied to come
to the complete class of problems you
need theta equals 1 and tau and Sigma
are chosen such that tau times Sigma
times this squared operator norm of your
linear operator is less than 1 so just
the product of both times this should be
less than 1 but you are free to choose
the ratio of those two here ok yes
because this is an overall equation here
exactly yes it's a relation yeah but
it's hard to say that it's the same so
it's not here it's not for making it
faster like in the SOR here is it that
you extrapolate your primer that it is
at the same time step as the dual such
that it's not running behind the dual
all the time otherwise you would already
get a stick sacking at the end so you
really need this for convergence here
and you can derive this algorithm by
means of a preconditioned augmented
Lagrangian and then this factor theta
equals 1 comes directly out so it's not
just hand chosen so you can derive it
from that another different algorithm
then you see exactly that theta is equal
to 1 here ok so what we proved in the
paper is that it gives different
conversions rates some in the terms of
the objective function some in terms of
X so coming back to your comment by
non-empirical choices on tau Sigma and
theater so if F star and G are non
smooth that means this really complete
class of problems we have conversions in
terms of the objective function of order
1 over N where n
the total number of iterations so
starting with initial error you can say
that the gap decreases with this order
here
it means if I mean interested in an
epsilon accurate solution I need 1 over
epsilon iterations to find the solution
here and for this convergence here for
this class of problems theater is fixed
to 1 and tau and Sigma R approach re
just add this restriction that the
product should be smaller than some
value has to be fulfilled so if one of
these two terms a uniform in convex so
it's related to strictly convex then we
can show that we have actually faster
conversions which is order of 1 over N
squared but now not for the objective
function but now for your unknown vector
here for this correct l2 no Meah that
means if you want to have a epsilon
accurate solution of in terms of X you
need 1 over square root of epsilon
iterations
sorry square root of epsilon iterations
now 1 over square root of n iterations
and finally if both terms are uniformly
convex that means you have really a
smooth differentiable problem
then we actually find linear convergence
here so that means convergence is in
terms of Omega to the power of n and
it's number of iterations and Omi's
Omega is less than 1 that means the
proof met in each step is the same
exactly Omega and this is again for the
squared error X minus the optimal
solution X hat here yeah it's always
convex so this is this class of problems
where F and G are convex but sometimes
it might be differentiable so like a
squared theta term is differentiable but
the total variation or l1 norm is non
differentiable so depending of the type
of problem you you end up with different
guarantees for your conversions here
no l2 is so our convergence rates we
obtained for the primary tool exactly
coincide with the best known rates of
all these algorithms of Nesterov
nemirovsky bhakti boo but they it's
important note that they have different
algorithms to achieve this and we can
achieve all these conventions that we've
basically the same algorithm so it
automatically somehow adapts to that to
the smoothness of the problems and gives
you the best convergence rate here so
but it's not it's not known if there's a
first order method which can be faster
than ours but these are currently the
best known rates we exactly achieve with
this algorithm so for details I refer to
the paper which can be downloaded from
my home page so let me now present some
performance evaluation of this algorithm
exactly for this free cases of different
smoothness the first one is again there
are or F model as mentioned before this
is something non smooth non
differentiable and this is something
smooth so we have the sum of something
smooth plus something non smooth
therefore we can apply this accelerated
algorithm which gives us 1 over N
squared this is just example image juice
this is the clean image the noisy image
this is a typically result of rof
denoising so here are the numbers we
evaluated the algorithm for different
strengths of the noise and effort
different regularization parameters here
lambda 16 which is a stronger theater
matthias lambda 8 less strong data term
needs more regularization and we related
it for different accuracies here for for
a given ground troop solutions of the
crown jewel solution was produced
running one algorithm for 100,000
iterations so one can see that for
stronger regulation the algorithm all
algorithms need more iterations and of
course if you require a higher accuracy
than you need
also more iterations so the fastest
method so far is still
the distance between wrong will and you
know epsilon here is the distance to the
ground truth solution so in terms of X
so or here in terms of you so you really
pre compute the optimal solution which
is unique here therefore it's okay but
sometimes it might not be unique so then
you cannot use it and then you measure
it just it's just the RMS root mean
squared error this is per pixel yes
so each pixel is U is accurate up to
this arrow here yes
reasonably accurate okay
there's one algorithm which is based on
this arrow of its method which is still
the fastest one you see here sixty five
iterations he is 600 here 105 one
thousand iterations but this method
cannot be proven to converge with in
this accuracy here so it it has the same
as an asymptotic convergence led rate
like 1 over N squared but it there's no
chance to prove it so all different
people tried it so it's still unknown
but beautifully it's very very fast but
this can this algorithm can only be
applied to this specific problem when
you apply it to a non smooth problem
then it stops working if our algorithm
is approximately as fast as very well
established methods like fist are of
baking taboo and Nesterov is a little
bit slower than fist but it's slightly
outperforms fist and messed up so you
can see here 108 a little bit slower but
here a little bit faster again a little
bit slower and and for higher accuracy a
little bit faster so it it really equals
established methods so now let's try to
do a similar experiment for a completely
non smooth problem now it's T we l1
denoising it also be familiar with this
type of the noising it's known that t be
l1 denoising is well suited if you have
strong outliers in your data them so
dealing with a lot of noise and strong
no it's like occlusions or speculoos of
whatever so here you have a clean image
this is some noisy image with salt and
pepper noise and this is what rof gives
you you see it's always smooth and still
have outliers inside and this is what
tl-one gives you here in this case so
this is again the example image used in
the revelation and we did a similar
comparison with state-of-the-art methods
and it turns out that the primal-dual
algorithm is much faster here we've
compared to alternating direction method
of multipliers this is the fragment
method or the extra gradient method of
next couple leverage and the nester of
smoothing method here so it's quite
disappointing that the nester of
smoothing method here is very very slow
the problem is the smoothing has to be
the order of your accuracy and just
smoothing the l1 Dom just with this
small epsilon here makes this nest of
algorithm really slow here in this case
and we don't need any kind of moving so
this moving is in there algorithm itself
somehow include it so and finally a
problem where both terms are smooth this
is for example given by the CUDA hooba
rof denoising model so here you have two
squared data term again and here you
have a smooth approximation of the l1
norm simply cubed function which is
quadratic here for small values and in
linear for larger values and therefore
both terms are smooth and we can apply
the linear convergent algorithm so it's
a comparison between arrow f and huber
you see this blocky artifacts of our f
denoising which comes from this total
variation regularization and since the
hooba uses some smooth approximation
gives you more smooth result it also
looks a little bit more natural here in
this case if we compared it to some
Nesterov method and as you can see it's
much faster here so for a very very
accurate solution now it's it's really
machine precision so this is where
matlab stops working here with this
accuracy here and it takes only 187
iterations so when you look at it
these timings here this is this all
refer to plain MATLAB implementations
you can easily paralyze it on the GPU
gives a speed-up of 300 500 depending on
your GPU this also applies to nester
from the other methods we tested as well
yes sorry the epsilon is the Icarus II
between your pixel value and the ground
truth pixel value what do you mean no no
this is just the comparison between rof
and huber so the what this is just tools
to show the effect of using a smooth
approximation of the total variation
instead of the pure total variation you
have to show the effect what you lose or
win when you do this this smoothing of
the Elwha no no no epsilon is the
accuracy of of your solution when
running the algorithm for the Hyuga
model yeah you use a different method or
one algorithm with a very large number
of iterations to produce the ground
truth solution and then you mentioned
sorry no because you you have noise and
there's no denoising algorithm which
gives you this here only an
approximation so it's not the ground to
restate the minimizer of your energy
it's the minimizer of this energy here
sorry the global minimum exactly yes yes
of course it's an image which yeah it
looks exactly like this so I I don't
think you see the difference of 10 to
the power of -15 so
that's why we have been asking these
questions because okay I misunderstood
you just like tea yeah maybe accuracy of
0.001 is enough yeah so yeah many refer
to this table here you have 10 minus 4
then I hate maybe 40 50 iterations so
very very fast
so having minds then on a chip you
weaken to 10,000 iterations per second
for example so that's a good thing about
the algorithm that each iteration is
very very fast
yeah okay do you need maybe many
iterations but each iteration is very
very fast I come back to this point when
you go back only for the non-smooth case
it's in terms of the function
well you here is it in terms of your
unknown but for a non-smooth case
there's there's no chance to write it in
terms of because it's explained before
okay what about parallel computing so
the algorithm basically in each step
computes matrix vector products with
usually a very very sparse matrix so
it's very easy to paralyze it therefore
the process of my dreams looks like this
I would like to have one simple
processor for each pixel maybe and each
processor only has a very small amount
of memory storing the primary the dual
value here and each processor should be
able to interchange data according to
the structure of your linear operator
that means for example only with unite
neighboring pixels this would be a very
very nice processor so you could have
for each pixel one processor and then
you could do one primary dual step
completely in parallel so and
recent GPS very much go into this
direction so therefore this algorithm is
very very well suited to be implemented
on on the GPU so state-of-the-art GPS
have about 500 course that means I can
update 500 pixels at the same time so
there's still room for improvement for
the algorithm namely if the linear
operator K has irregular structure that
means not this nice structure given by
find the differences approximation or
wavelet if it's really bad so for
example one column is completely dense
the next column is too sparse or
whatever or the operator K is badly
scaled some entries are in the range
between 0 0 and 1 some are in the range
between 0 and 10 millionths then the
performance of the algorithm drops down
and the operator norm which is necessary
to bound the time steps is very hard to
estimate if the structure is very
irregular it's another point second the
global steps tau and Sigma that are just
scalar valued steps might not be able to
adapt to this more complicated structure
of your linear operator and this
motivates the study of reconditioning
techniques for the primal-dual algorithm
so it goes like this
thanks to this paper here of here and
John it was only if a few months ago
they showed that our primal-dual
algorithm is a special instance of this
proximal point algorithm maybe you
remember I mentioned this is this non
implementable algorithm they show that
this is just a clever splitting of this
proximal point algorithm and the
iterations of the proximal point
algorithm can be written it the
following variational inequality that
means doing one step in the primal and
the dual
means solving this variational
inequality here for xn plus 1 by n plus
1 so meaning finding this xn plus 1 by n
plus 1 such that its larger equals 0 is
doing one step of the primal-dual
algorithm
it's just rewriting the iterations in a
in a fancy way here and what is included
here is this iteration matrix M and for
the primal-dual algorithm presented
before M looks like this you have here
that giant operator minus K star and you
here you have minus theta times K and
here you have 1 over tau times identity
and 1 over Sigma times identity so now
it is known like this can be seen as a
norm in this matrix M here that
convergence is ensured as long as M is
symmetric and positive-definite so for
constructing norms you always need to
this condition on your matrix here and
now coming back to your question now you
see that if teacher is not one that this
is surely not symmetric so teeth Cheeta
has to be one such that this thing here
is symmetric and of course this is some
diagonal matrix diagonal matrix so we
are done and I should note that for the
accelerated versions where Tita is
allowed to change dynamically so I did
not show the teeth but you can look it
up in the paper then it's no longer
proximal point but this deplane
algorithm with theta equals 1 this
algorithm the primal-dual algorithm is
exactly instance of the proximal point
algorithm so what do we need we need
that this is symmetric when theta 1 we
find and it should be positive definite
and it's not difficult to show that this
matrix is positive definite exactly when
tau times Sigma times the squared
operator norm of K is less than 1 it's
exactly the condition we had in the
paper so can be recovered from a
different viewpoint here so now the
basic idea is yes yes you can you can
choose any yes now just have to fulfill
this this variation inequality here
so the basic idea of the preconditioning
now is why not to replace your scaler
Elliott primary dual steps tau and Sigma
by positive definite symmetric matrices
tau and Sigma so that means we replace
this iteration matrix M of the original
algorithm of our first paper by this
matrix here where now we have here the
matrix tau and the matrix the inverse of
the matrix Sigma here so the intuition
parent is that using here a matrix and
here matrix and set of scalars we have
much more degrees of freedom which gives
us some chance to improve the
convergence of the algorithm so the
preconditions primal-dual algorithm now
looks like this
it's just the same algorithm and instead
of having here the time steps Sigma we
have the matrix here here the matrix
here the matrix and here the matrix
otherwise stick the algorithm is exactly
the same so now it's of course there the
question is interesting what should tow
and Sigma fulfill such that the
algorithm converges and it turns out
that convergence can be ensured if theta
equals 1 as before to make it symmetric
here tau and Sigma are symmetric and
positive-definite and square root of
Sigma times K times square root of tau
squared should be less than 1 and now
it's very easy if you replace here Sigma
and tau by this matrix you exactly Rick
recover this condition here it's the
same condition written in matrix form
him okay now we know having these
matrices we can ensure convergence which
ensure which obey this inequality here
and equations now how to choose sigmund
town this very important because the
pre-conditioner should be chosen such
that the proximity operators are still
easy to compute this was the main
assumption of the algorithm that these
proximity operators are easy to compute
and the effort from now will restrict
our briton preconditioning matrices to
diagonal matrices
that means that we now have one time
step for each dimension of the problem
so for each entry of the vector X and
the dual vector Y we have one time step
general the algorithm converges for a
complete matrix but then they proximity
operators are more difficult to compute
in some special cases we have some ideas
how to use a complete matrix but from
now let us stick to diagonal matrices
here and what we showed in our work is
that if you choose tau and Sigma exactly
like this then you can ensure
convergence so what does this mean
K is your linear operators and matrix
you choose the chain entry of tau as the
norm of the chafed column of k1 over the
entries in the palm of the Jade column
of K and you choose the eath entry of
Sigma of the vector Sigma here as the
norm of the eighth row of K the chance
to take your matrix compute column bias
norms with respect to 2 minus alpha and
alpha and robust norms and 1 over these
norms exactly give it a time steps and
what we show is that exactly this choice
for the preconditioning ensures the
important inequalities such to the
algorithm converges so for example
choose alpha equals to 1 then you have
exactly here del Valle non-material
Bonham that's basically what we use ok
that means the good thing about this
preconditioning is that you can really
use the algorithm in a plug-and-play
fashion even a problem with a linear
operator i compute roll column bias
norms robust norms this gives me the
time steps and then no longer have to
estimate the operator norm of k or
somehow choose my time steps here so
there was a surprise when doing this
that there is a very strong connection
to a very old method with this
preconditioning namely the alternating
step method of unit on Eckstein and
Pettis they considered a sub class of
problems the so-called mono tropic
programs
consists of the following thing you
minimize objectifying to achieve some
something convex subject to this
equality constraints here okay and you
can rewrite these by means of a saddle
point problem you end up with this
formulation here it it's easy to see
that this is exactly one instance of the
saddle point problems we consider here
in this talk today and it turns out that
when I use alpha equals to zero the
precondition primer dual algorithm is
exactly the alternating step method of
extent of of 1990 that was quite a
surprise so what does alpha equals zero
mean here it's easy it's kisses correct
numb but here you have to the power of
series simply the number of nonzero
entries in the eighth row of your matrix
but it turns out that different choices
for alpha we use alpha equals one
performed better in practice so
therefore they're alternating step
method can be recovered as a special
case of this precondition primal dual
algorithm here so here's a short
emulation on general linear programming
problems where we compared the primal
dual algorithm the standard of the first
part then the precondition primal dual
algorithm and we use just one interior
points over here so we use free and P
test problems and the eros threshold was
ten to the power of minus four this was
basically the the normalized primal dual
cap is the same of match-ups interior
points or bodies using so we have three
problems one is called SC 50p you can
find it in matlab it's included in
matlab and it's a very small LP problem
only 48 variables 30 inequalities and 20
qualities the second one is a bad least
K problem they have a dense column
therefore it's called dense columns and
slightly more variable as 1677 variables
in 627 equalities the third one was an
LP formulation of T V l1 denoising so
when replacing that total variation by
some anisotropic Toleration you can
write it as an LP problem and
we applied it to a reasonable large
image so that we had around 800,000
unknowns so the first observation is for
these small problems we cannot beat the
imperial points over its no no chance so
the Imperial interior point server takes
only 0.01 seconds here for this problem
here it's also very very fast and the
primer to world and the preconditioned
of course slower here so they're in for
this first problem the precondition
primal dual algorithm yeah is about how
much is it three times faster than the
pre primal dual algorithm but for this
badly scaled problem the precondition
primer duel I give this much mass faster
here as you can see 0.6 second versus
270 seconds here in this case and for
the large-scale problem it was quite
interesting to see that we can very very
easily outperform an interior point
Zorba so it only takes 15 iterations but
a hitch iteration takes so long that in
summary we it takes 1700 seconds to
compute this LP large LP program and the
primer duel and the precondition prime
module are very fast in this case here
of course when you paralyze this
algorithm maybe we can beat interior
points or but you know it's only very
few variables it's even less variables
than than processes on the cheaper so
it's not very reasonable but this wasn't
a point to show here ok so now I come to
the application section yeah maybe I
write it down on the blackboard so the
isotropic let's say you have you is it's
your image and you have nabla you that
means it's something nabla Xu and now by
you
okay the gradient is a vector of course
and the isotropic thing is I call it to
1 is to sum over all pixels until you
have the square root of
nabla xu i j squared
last novel of why you I J squared this I
called the isotropic it's not completely
isotropic but almost and the anisotropic
it's just the l1 norm which is to sum
over IJ and here you have the absolute
value of X direction I J plus the
absolute value of the Y direction of UI
J yes it's degrading yes exactly so it
looks like K is nabla is some matrix
here of minus 1 1 minus 1 1 just finite
differences can you say it again the
primal-dual I go from yeah yes for this
operator there's no difference between
the standard algorithm the
preconditioned because it's completely
irregular so it gives you the same thing
as the operator norm there's no
difference
but in many many problems you don't have
this nice structure we have here some
dense columns or whatever and then it's
the difference is very very huge you're
right yes because at the boundary you
somehow say that the gradient is zero
that means the last thing here is zero
so there's a different row and column
number of course yeah but I checked this
it's not too huge different but you're
right ok so the first application so you
can interpret the total variation maybe
as as the simplest form of structured
sparsity sparsity in this case means the
positions by the gradient jumps where
does it discontinuity is jump so I only
have a few positions in the image very
champs so there's no reason why not to
replace your novel operator by something
richer for example a very flat transform
or a curved blade transform side here so
the model basically stays the same just
replace your
elaborated by something more rich so
then the model looks like this this is
also very related to the basest person
problem and the seven-point formulation
looks like this way just dual eyes this
L bottom here so now i show a image in
painting example this is the original
image and 80% of the lines were lost so
for compressed sensing this is very bad
because from compress sensing you know
it should be randomly so this is not
completely randomly because you always
remove one complete line when you do
total variation in painting it looks
like this because it just minimizes the
sum over all level lines at the length
of all level lines in the image that's
very bad and if you use a curve that
transform the image looks like this so
the same input but better K operator
gives you this that means that the kerf
transfer might be a better prior for
natural images so when you compare it so
you see for example here this thin trunk
it's not very much improved okay not a
very very important model in computer
vision is the Potts model which has been
used in huge number of applications like
image segmentation scene labeling stereo
optic flow whatever here is a continuous
formulation in the continuous setting a
Potts model is written as given an image
domain Omega I want to find a partition
of the image domain in two sets a L such
that the union of all sets should give
me my image domain and they should be
pairwise disjoint so it means there's no
overlap in the hole in between and the
post model consists of minimizing the
sum over all boundary length or
perimeters of the set plus the integral
over some given weight function FL here
for each set okay so a convex
representation of this non convex model
if the following you introduced labeling
function theta L so it's between 0 & 1
this labeling function is relaxed so
that it can take
intermediate values so the data term is
easy to rewrite it just Tita L times FL
if theta L is 0 then FL is not counted
if one then it is counted and some term
which should measure the boundary length
and then it's subject to this constraint
it should be large equal 0 and the sum
over all T to L at one point should be
equal to 1 of course they do that's
their usual simplex constraint here so
note that for k1 you exactly can recover
binary image segmentation to this graph
cut for example the most straightforward
relaxation is exactly to use the total
variation independently for each of the
labeling function this had been proposed
by Christopher and Gallup Amanita and
0-8 Christoph attack I mean and a better
realization was proposed together with
Antonelli
Daniel and host cvpr 2009 so which is
slightly more difficult as you can see
from here but it's it's nothing less
than a better relaxation of the boundary
length fear so here's a comparison this
is their famous triple point problem so
given this boundary datum you want to do
something like in painting of this great
zoom here and with the simple relaxation
of Christophe attack it gives you
something blurry here so it gives you no
binary values meaning the location is
not tight enough and our title
relaxation gives it exactly or almost
exactly a binary decision here so this
is of course subject to the
discretization error view here's the for
every problem what do you think how does
they reset look like who has a guess
only these guesses allowed you don't
know it right what do you think not a
forum for our approach but doing a free
surface so it looks like this so it
gives you free are two triple junctions
because it's known from the man for
child problem so the pots model is a is
a special case of the mouse
a problem that only triple junctions
allowed there are no four junctions on
the triple junctions with 120 degrees
allowed and this is exactly covered by
this Potts model here so it's not
possible that all four phases meet in
one point here so here's an example for
ya white gray matter segmentation of a
brain yes I mean this line here I think
it will give you the same so it's pretty
yeah it's a spanning tree problem so
this exactly minimizes the sum over a
total interface length so you will
always find they meet the minimum
interface length here and shifting this
one pixel I don't think it will change
too much yes so this is one image
segmentation example for medical imaging
so you can easily sigmat this into 1 2 3
4 faces here and then you can recover
approximation of image here this is an
example with 16 labors so what is
different to graph cut here is that for
example using the earth expansion we
don't to solve a sequence of minor
problem solve the complete problem at
once with the primal-dual algorithm here
so this is always something very nice
this is the triple junction in 3d so we
take a cube that has 6 faces and we
fixed always two faces to one labor so 2
faces were right two faces were black
and two faces by gray and this is the
final result of the interface and join
one slice through this final volume
gives you exactly this thing and this is
a rendering of one of forks
right the banner the final reason is
consist consists of three of these
objects here and you can block this free
object together to recover the cube here
them so here's another example for
stereo as mentioned before you can use
the Potts model for stereo as well here
is one example for the tacuba dataset it
has 64 Labour's or sub pixel accuracy it
takes about seven point seven seconds on
a Tesla GPU to solve it and here even
more Labour's it's 256 Labour's and it's
about 175 seconds on a and a Tesla to be
you to solve the problem here so so the
next application is optical flow so as
you all might know is one of the central
topics in computer vision is optical
flow and the idea is to compute a vector
field that describes the projected
motion the projected 3d motion of the
objects onto the image brain and it
should give you a pair of pixel motion
so to say so here I see one example I'm
holding a book in front of my face and
it's its moves and it's very easy for
you to see okay there's a rotation going
on and this is what the algorithm can
compute and you can even see that the
algorithm is not perfect because it
cannot decide better the background
belongs to the object because there's no
texture or it does not belong which is
easy for human which okay say this is
the right thing in the background which
does not move and this is a just another
representation of the flow field using a
color coding scheme standard thing in
computer vision here so they hue is
something the direction and the
saturation is how fast it moves so
basically the optical flow is computed
here and in this algorithm using the
linearized brightness Constanza
assumption that means your main
assumption is that the intensity of a
pixel does not change that means the
intensity at some position X and some
time T is equal to the intensity of the
move pixel s plus VB is the flow at t
plus one so and when linearizing this
you end up with this so-called optical
flow constraint
nice brightness constancy assumption
here this is the time derivative and
this is the space derivative here and
you have to do this around some pre
given point v-0 and the limitation of
course is only well it in a small
neighborhood around v-0 so what we used
in the paper is a slightly improved
linear rest of the flow constraint we'd
say ok it's very likely today
intensities might change but we think we
assume they only change smoothly and you
consider this modified optically flow
constraint where we say ok it should not
be equal to 0 it should be equal to
minus U or plus u equals 0 here ok
now I have many many pictures so it's no
more formulas or almost no formulas this
is one example of the optical flow this
is one of the input images of the
middlebury database this is the ground
truth flow color-coding this is what the
algorithm gives us and this is the
intensity changes of the improved
optical flow constraint here you see
here there are some shadows which are
here we covered exactly so I have a demo
here because this can be computed in the
chippy on real time I hope it works
let me just decrease the number of
iterations here
so so here's the import image maybe I
should close this one oh research code
okay I will not close it okay maybe I
just show you the color coding so here
this flickering comes from from the
adaption of the camera you see when I
move the color coding if I increase the
regularization parameter let's say to
200 becomes much more noisy and if I
decrease it to let's say 20 then it is
much more smooth so the flickering
really comes because they use B camera
somehow adapts to the change in light
it's the flickering of the lamps here so
in here it runs now it's on this laptop
it's 10 frames per second for 640 x 480
here so on the desktop GPU it's 5 6
times faster okay so now I come to the
last application which is online 3d
reconstruction so what we do is we use
the PTM framework of klein Emery to
track the camera in real time and we
based on the keyframes provided by P
time maybe you're familiar with p.m. we
compute stereo images using the optical
flow algorithm because you can restrict
optical flow to stereo and then we do a
volumetric tap map fusion approach which
we developed together with list of
attack in the basic idea is you have a
volume and the surface II is represented
as the assigned distance so as the zero
level set of a signed distance function
and you take all your range images
obtained by the optical flow algorithm
and you construct sight distance
function based on this range
informations and dangered where
denoising of all the scientist ins
function to 3d volume so basically what
we have is for each voxel hodes a
histogram of that
distance hypothesis we have faced a gram
of 10 bins and then we have this TBL one
energy this exactly minimizes the
surface area because the total relation
is known to minimize the surface area of
the file 3d reconstruction and this is
just the l1 distance to all pins of the
histograms so this is a very nice scene
so it's highly texture to it easy to
compute this is how they signed distance
function a volume looks like and this is
how they final surface looks like okay I
also have a Deema for this so here on
the here on the laptop I have to
decrease the resolution of the of the
volume of course so this is now
everything computed online it's just the
video instead of the camera input so
this is not a tracking of PTM and
unfortunately because I only have one
chip you in the laptop there sometimes
it will stop because computing it on the
GPU blocks representing something on the
screen so now while you're moving it
starts to reconstruct okay the still
there Frede seen here okay here we go
and when it gets more input data more
keyframes you can compute more range
images and the tl-one regularization is
computed on the GPU while new range
images are constructed so if I think
it's too noisy then I can decrease the
organization parameter here and then it
should be a little bit cleaner as you
can have a better surface interpolation
it looks nicer so here you see the
fretwork so it gives the GPU much work
to do and this bar shows how many range
images are still to process so it can
deal with concavities as you can see
like this door here and and Bogota yeah
that's it basically so everything is
computed with this primal-dual algorithm
here so maybe a stop here come back to
to mislead sorry okay yes I now if the
conclusion so I've presented that first
of the primal-dual algorithm for convex
cellphone problems in computer vision
and it comes along with the over
conversion rates for different problem
classes and I also proposed a simple
preconditioning scheme which allows to
use the Elgar from their plug-and-play
fashion and simply try it yes thank you